بوابه الدواء قاعده تعمل وعندها قسم اثار
حاليا قاعدين يعملون اعمال تنقيب بكل هذيك
المنطقه بشكل عام بس الى الان لانه بدات
على حسب علمي من سنه مع تاسيس بوابه
الدرعيه فالى الان لسه ما اعلنوا عن
الدراسات اللي طلعت ويعني في هذيك المنطقه
بس في اعمال تنقيب قاعده تصير حاليا في
هذيك المنطقه بس انه سنتين اعتقد يعني وقت
جدا متاخر يعني ما في قبل ان تعرفي العلا
كان فيها اعمال من من ازمنه قديمه يعني
بعثات فرنسيه او بس بناخذ كمان بعين
الاعتبار ان هذيك المنطقه اول كان كلها
سكان
فعمله هم لما نسرب منطقه درعيه بشكل عام
صار في سلطه اكثر لان في ناس مثلا طلعوا
من مناطقهم او غيرها لان في اسباب مثلا من
عندك مواقع اثريه في كمان للاسف بعضها
اتدمرت لان مع استيطان السكان وتوسع
المدينه وغيرها لكن على الاقل يعني الحمد
لله نقول ان في استم راريه
يعني الان قاعدين يعني تقول يسعفونها
وينقذونها